alright I'm gonna level with you I knew
nothing about this movie other than you
know spies and Michael Fassbender and
that was enough for me to be like
awesome haywire
all right so hey wires directed by
Steven Soderbergh and I was like okay
Ocean's eleven guy in spies and that's
awesome now we revealing the spy movies
hard because I can't ruin things for you
because there's a lot to ruin in this
movie so I'll be careful don't worry no
spoilers pretty much what you need to
know is there's this one spy chick and
other spy people are going after this
spy chick and so half the movie shows
you why they're going after her and what
happened before and the other half is
like you know from this point on you
know basic cool spy movie now from
the get-go you see the first fight in
this movie and immediately I was like
this feels really real you know there
are fights and movies that are supremely
choreographed you're like oh okay yeah
it just looks all cool and fancy these
are well choreographed but you can tell
this chick can actually throw down she
can kick some ass
turns out she's an MMA fighter named
Gina someone Gina could kick Jeremy's
ass that's her new last name she's
really sexy too dude she is she's sexy
in that Katee Sackhoff ish kind of you
know hot and could beat the piss out of
you kinda way which is you know that's
cool but also what makes the fights
really realistic in this movie is the
fact that there's no music that ever
plays during any fight that just makes
it feel really gritty really real and
just really in your face you're like
yeah I can buy this this is exactly how
this kind of fight would go down and
after that really cool spy stuff and
plot twists and chase scenes and that's
what I really liked about this movie
this movie felt really real I don't know
what the budget of this movie was but
this is how I'd explain it haywire is
mission impossible if Mission Impossible
had the budget of snatch like the movie
not to come on I had heard this and then
I googled it after I watched the movie I
guess the main chick's voice is actually
not her voice it's redubbed you read
double voice for one of a few reasons
one she's foreign and he can't
understand a word she says he's not
foreign so it can't be that two voice
doesn't really fit the character like
ray parks voice was dubbed in the
Phantom Menace forget I even used that
analogy aunt Beru was dubbed in Star
Wars but I saw interviews with her and
it looks like her voice would fit the
character so I don't think it's that and
three build the actress just sucks might
be that not sure but I'm just saying
although I hope it's not that because I
think the actress was really good you
know
for her actions and facial expressions
don't know about her voice just I didn't
hear it but beyond that the other actors
were really good too and there are some
good actors in this movie you got Ewan
McGregor Antonio Banderas Gordon Gekko
or Michael Douglas as most of you know
Michael Fassbender is a Fassbender or
Faust bender I'm always gonna call him
Faust bender because it sounds like I
have an accent it makes it sound cooler
he's in the movie kind of what can I say
he's a cameo if you're watching this
movie for Faust bender he's a cameo so
don't put all your hopes and dreams on
that but there's enough stuff to like in
this movie it's a flawless now it's not
flawless sometimes the plot seems really
convoluted in that spy kind of way I
mean you can't have too much in a spy
movie if it's done well it'll feel like
Ocean's eleven if it's not it'll feel
like Ocean's Twelve this movie worked
for me that characters work for me the
excitement worked for me I loved how the
fighting felt so real and the movie just
felt real in general I will say it's a
good time no alcohol required if you
like realistic spy stuff like mission
impossible I'm snatches budget go check
this movie out haywire and it has a
really sexy fighter chick who could beat
the living out of me which is I'm
fine with it punch me you know so your
favorite spy movie you gotta have when
everyone has a favorite spy movie what
would it be
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you